I mean some of the some of the greatest
moments that a child has are precisely
because he's unencumbered by
responsibilities you know like we also
organize our society in a way that
doesn't permit us to be very present
right you got a hustle and you know you
got to be in an anxious state to get
ahead you know and we've inherited that
from the anxious states of being ahead
you know when we lived in the savannahs
of Africa we had to be one step ahead of
the Predators and now we have to be one
step ahead of our competitors it's the
same thing but you know don't you it's
it's it's even a blade of grass becomes
a magnificent world in itself have given
proper attention like if we if we were
freed from the constraints burdening
that limited Faculty of our attention
maybe we could redirect it towards just
the miracle of being alive right
consciousness itself could be more
indulgent upon its capacities to
contemplate no I often I'm like a quote
or order yeah but the reason for that
you know my mother's a teacher and she's
taught for 40 years high school
literature and in her classroom walls
she always had beautiful quotes written
like really big all over the walls right
and granted that's literature but
English class is really the class that
teaches you how to be a human being
right you know in math class there's
numbers on the walls and chemistry class
there's chemistry equations on the walls
in English class you have beautiful
quotes that tell you how to be a better
person on the wall mines are like
parachutes they only function when open
practice random kindness and senseless
acts of beauty like these are the cause
that are on the wall and so I I think I
kind of acquired that same impulse to
surround myself by the ideas that point
the way constantly right the wallpaper
of my mind is filled with quotes that
are like post-it notes that remind me
about the states of subjective
well-being that I want to live inside of
so wonder in awe are huge ones for me
and so I collect a lot of quotes about
that and obviously there's a lot of
cognitive benefits of being in a state
of awe and wonder there's a lot there
was an essay that I read once called the
death of awe in the age of awesome
and Henry wise Meyer wrote it you guys
should look up the piece it's great but
he talks about how or f scott Fitzgerald
writing about wonder he says that wonder
is a transitory enchanted moment in
which man must have held his breast
compelled into an aesthetic
contemplation he neither understood nor
desired face to face was something can
measure it this capacity for wonder you
think about that when was the last time
you were face to face with something can
measure it to your capacity for wonder
when was the last time that you
completely eclipsed the binned there's
and done that's of the adult mind that
you were freed from the tedium of the
daily and thrust into the numinous like
when was the last time you had a
religious experience as a secular person
and what I mean by that it was an
experience that carried you outside
yourself an exhilarating neuro storm of
such intellectual pleasure of such
cognitive ecstasy that you basically had
a mind gasm right an aesthetic orgasm
and that that that's healing as
experiences they experiences these
experiences make us whole and these
experiences make us holy